from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between ben and jerry's in the uk and
the us this is food wars
in the uk ben jerry's comes with a
standard tub size of 465 milliliters and
the coarse tubs are the same size
nice little cute guy in the us we start
with these mini tubs they're 118
milliliters or four ounces a standard us
ben and jerry's pint is 16 ounces or 473
milliliters and also like in the uk our
cores this guy right here is the same
size as our regular height our top tubs
are actually slightly smaller they are
15.2 fluid ounces or 450 milliliters
one thing to note is that despite the
two being very similar sizes the uk does
not refer to its tubs as pints that's
because pints are actually different in
the uk and the us here in the u.s we
measure our liquids using u.s customary
measurements which is based on an 18th
century english so who cares all right
our pint is 16 fluid ounces in the uk we
use imperial measurements which were
only established in 1824 after the us
had declared independence our pints are
568 milliliters which is 1.2 times
larger than a us point to illustrate the
difference i've brought in an imperial
measurements measuring jug we're going
to fill it with ice cream
it just looks like the best milkshake
you've ever had honestly
according to target this is 16 fluid
ounces so we're going gonna put this in
here and see what happens and in case
you still don't believe us this is a
british pint glass we're gonna fill this
with ice cream
i've got this pint in front of me it
would be kind of rude not to try
wouldn't it cheers
[Music]
i found the wallet it was going really
well then i hit a lump i'm down to about
here though pretty strong i think
it's the lumps that get you but honestly
not the worst way to eat bed and
cherries i mean as much as i can get
then i guess start eating it how's that
fun fact this is actually how ryan
gosling ended up gaining 60 pounds for a
movie role which he then got fired from
so it ended up being a little bit of a
waste of time but pretty effective way
to pile on mass now while the volume of
ice cream you get in the two countries
is theoretically pretty similar one
other thing we wanted to check was how
much topping you get mixed in with your
tub here's a pint of cookie dough in the
u.s we've let it melt so we're going to
strain it to see how many cookie dough
chunks are in a pint we'll do the same
over here let's go oh yeah that ice
cream is totally catching up with me
right now
i swear to god if i throw up the side of
this reminds me of the net used to catch
bugs in animal crossing
with the little
yes this is completely arbitrary here we
go
it doesn't look very appetizing when you
put it like that does it have to sift
through this i guess yeah there's not
one
two
just another day at the office really
isn't it 12 13 15. so in a uk tub of
cookie dough we got around 33 pieces of
actual cookie dough in varying sizes
while we're going into excruciating
detail on the portion sizes why not take
a look at the cause tubs as well
here's the same flavor in the u.s let's
cut this bad boy open
i can still eat this after i've sewn it
in half is there anything any chemicals
on here that are likely to
kill me we'll find out
[Music]
that core doesn't go all the way i mean
it's kind of like
chocolate vanilla
salted caramel cool
just pick it
i mean i didn't wash the sauce
woody oak flavor
here are all the ben jerry's items
you'll find in the uk that you won't
find in the u.s and here are most
actually half of the u.s exclusive ben
and jerry's flavors we'll start with
this one which is the birthday cake ice
cream i haven't actually tried this
before but apparently it's vanilla cake
batter ice cream with pink frosting
strawberry swirls and cake pieces
americone dream this is the stephen
colbert flavored ice cream i'm not quite
sure what steve tastes like but looks
like they got his essence in this pint
speaking of ice cream that is person
flavored the tonight dough you see that
right there
there is
absolutely no way that's his hand
holding that gun good job on the
photoshop those guys the berry sweet
mascarpone another one you can only get
here in the u.s would be something i'll
be straight up with you as an italian
man i'm about to say something very
controversial but this flavor when i saw
it i was like yuck no thank you where is
it it is literally the first one in
front of me ben and jerry's cannoli
flavored any marsh capone ice cream with
fudge covered the pastry shell pieces of
marscapone squirrels squirrels swirls
next up we've got this one which is
cookie dough switch up next up we've got
the doble chocolate cookie dough twist
caramel chocolate cheesecake this is a
no-brainer right here i bet this one's
pretty good what's in the u.s caramel
cheesecake ice cream with cheesecake
pieces chocolate cookie swirls hell yeah
dude this is going in the joe pile
cherry garcia they don't have
cherry garcia in the uk it doesn't seem
weird this is like when everyone found
out about ben and jerry's i feel like
cherry garcia was i have no idea if this
was before jerry garcia died or in
tribute of him chocolate peanut butter
split i'm gonna assume it's chocolate
and peanut butter what do you guys think
chocolate therapy chocolate ice cream
with chocolate cookies and swirls of
chocolate pudding like every consistency
of chocolate that's chubby hubby i
thought this one's like super popular
chunky monkey was earlier it was banana
and walnuts and
it's the one i drank
it's not sitting right
next up we've got cone together which
i'm guessing is a come together pun did
the beatles do come together i really
i'm not a beatles guy i just listened to
owl city so i'm not the person to come
to for classic music advice cinnamon bun
tastes like cinnamon buns coffee coffee
buzz buzz buzz
maybe this instead of your morning
coffee
coffee toffee bar crunch
everything but the dot dot dots
he has a lot of stuff in here give me
some more
glam fire trail mix go to cold room
another coffee one next up we've got
baked alaska now i've actually never
eaten a proper baked alaska but i
presume it tastes similar to this this
has got vanilla ice cream with
marshmallow swirls and white polar bears
then we go on to the caramel chuchu ice
cream new york baby super fudge chunk
salted caramel almond not as many punny
ones as i thought right vanilla caramel
fudge i wonder what's in it milk and
cookies
peanut butter half baked it was a
combination of the two most popular ones
that's pretty smart actually what this
is crazy this can't be right vanilla why
don't you have vanilla in the uk then
our last classic tub is so far so good
together i'm not sure why they needed
the together i feel like the pun works
better without them together ben and
jerry if you're listening fix this the
punch line
chilling on the roast truffles pistachio
pistachio oat of this swirl okay now
right now we're getting back on the puns
strawberry cheesecake
and this isn't even all of them in the
u.s you can also get flavors such as
boots on the moon brewed tomato
chocolate shake it cold brew caramel
latte ice cream sammy justice remix mint
chocolate cookie peanut butter world red
white and blueberry triple caramel chunk
urban bourbon pumpkin cheesecake totally
unbaked that's just the regular ones we
got a lot more to go through we also
have a few non-dairy and low calorie
exclusives in the uk we'll start at the
end with this one which is save us world
now then we have one more non-dairy
exclusive which is this one cookies on
cookie dough here in the u.s you can get
the in non-dairy form americone dream
and the tonight dough milk
and cookies cherry garcia chocolate
caramel cluster and mint chocolate
cookie uh caramel almond brittle creme
brulee cookie ooh the netflix and
chilled peanut butter have baked and
fish food a few other flavors you can
get in the u.s you can't get in the uk
non-dairy that i also couldn't get in
the us but i've assumed are available
somewhere in this country are the
caramel sutra core non-dairy the coconut
seven layer bar non-dairy and the coffee
caramel fudge non-dairy then we're onto
some low calorie options which ben
jerry's calls mu fourier now this one up
here is a chocolate cookie dough low
calorie version but it's only 136
calories per 100 milliliters our next
mufouria exclusive flavor is the salted
caramel brownie one the next moofora
exclusive we were able to get was this
one poppin popcorn the muforia life
flavors you can get in the u.s are
chocolate cookie enlightenment
enlightened mints m-i-n-t
very good ben jerry's chocolate milk and
cookies mocha fudge brownie pb
marshmallow i'm slightly against the
concept of low calorie ice cream i feel
like with something like this you just
have to enjoy it as it was intended to
be enjoyed which is
the proper way if you're going to save
some calories maybe just save them
elsewhere and then treat yourself or
just eat less of one of these instead of
a whole top of that as you saw when i
hacked one open with a saw ben jerry's
also sells cause ice cream which is ice
cream flavors with a core of usually
some kind of caramel filling in the
middle we've only got one exclusive over
here which is this one the blondie
brownie core we got the course in the us
we got a bunch of course you can't get
in the uk the boom chocolata cookie core
chocolate chip cookie dough core sweet
like sugar cookie dough core week and no
bake cookie dough core brownie batter
core cookies and cream cheesecake core
peanut butter fudge core and salted
caramel core we got all eight of them
right here in the u.s we can also get
these exclusive topped pints now from
what i understand because i've never had
one the ice cream has a layer of topping
you used to be able to get these in the
uk but now you can't anymore whiskey biz
the pb over the top and the tiramisu but
you can also get a strawberry top and a
thick mint top
frozen yogurt
us ben and jerry's also has two frozen
yogurt options whereas the uk does not
have any sorry guys but we can get
frozen yogurt versions of cherry garcia
and half baked
all right in the u.s we got these mini
tubs you can get them in four flavors i
can only find one you get them in
americone dream cherry garcia non-dairy
caramel chocolate chunk and non-dairy
pband cookies i've actually never had
cherry garcia
going to the palette
oh that's a pen right there baby
similarly to the top tubs we also used
to be able to get mini subs in the uk
but unfortunately they were recently
discontinued outside of tubs of ice
cream ben jerry's also has some no spoon
needed options in the uk this is an
exclusive one right here which is a
cookie dough piece pop we do not have
the no spoon options but we do have the
pint slices you can get them in the
forms of amaze mint americone dream
cherry garcia chocolate chip cookie
dough chocolate fudge brownie and the
tonight dough final no spoon kneaded
exclusive we have here in the uk is this
one which is salted caramel cookie dough
chunks cookie dough chunks we got them
too
and these are some of the exclusive
cookie dough chunk bags from ben and
jerry's you can get in the u.s you got
sugar cookie dough so i mentioned really
half baked six ounces for some reason
all the other ones are eight i don't
know why they did that the chocolate
chip cookie dough
and peanut butter chocolate chip cookie
dough you can also get the tonighto
cinnabundo gingerbread cookie dough and
a vegan chocolate chip cookie dough one
u.s exclusive ben jerry's item that
people i assure you i tried i tried i
tried to get my hands on it in time of
the shooting just couldn't happen ben
and jerry also has two dog flavor ice
creams now they're not flavored like
dogs they're flavors for dogs the doggy
desserts is what they're calling them
and uh the two flavors are poochies mix
and rosie's batch so unfortunately no
doggo wars this episode but here are the
pictures of paul and luda
here's a picture of ice cream
can someone in graphics make it look
like they're eating the ice cream
quick clarification before we start the
nutrition section ice cream is kind of
tricky to quantify because sometimes
it's referred to by weight and other
times by volume it is because the
containers are all the same size yes but
the density of ice cream can vary so
overall seems the fairest way to measure
is by weight in the uk ben jerry's
provides its nutritional information per
100 grams whereas in the us they do it
per serving size which is around 141 or
142 grams depending on which type of ice
cream you have so if we divide the us
serving by 1.41 or 1.42 we should get a
roughly equivalent figure got it let's
start with what is officially the most
popular ben jerry's flavor in the united
states that is this the half baked 100
grams of usa's half baked contains 262
calories 13.4 grams of fat 7.8 of which
are saturated fat 31.9 grams of carbs
25.5 grams of sugar and 90 milligrams of
sodium 100 grams of uk half bait
contains the following 264 calories 13
grams of fat 8.1 grams of which is
saturated 32 grams of carbs of which 27
grams are sugar and 84 milligrams of
sodium so it looks like the uk's is
actually higher in saturated fat carbs
calories and sugar although the us edges
us on total fat and sodium what is the
most calorific flavor in the us you ask
turns out is the peanut butter cup
i couldn't find it this magically
delicious peanut butter cup flavored ben
and jerry's ice cream that is somewhere
in this country 100 grams of it contains
the following 330 calories 23.3 grams of
fat 12.6 of those are saturated fat 25.3
grams of carbs 22.5 grams which are
sugar and 126 milligrams of sodium the
same ice cream in the uk contains 310
calories 21 grams of fat of which 12
grams is saturated 24 grams of carbs of
which 23 grams are sugar and 176
milligrams of sodium this time we edge
the ucan calories fat saturated fat and
carbs while they beat us on sugar and
sodium now these 100 gram figures don't
seem so bad but bear in mind that they
are for less than one serving
realistically i'm eating a whole tub of
this while cuddle up in my blankets
depressed watching netflix if you were
to eat a whole pint of the peanut butter
cup ice cream don't the stats do not
look good for you two figures to watch
out for would be the 270 percent of your
daily saturated fat allowance and almost
200
of your daily sugar
here are the numbers for a full tub of
peanut butter cup in the uk keep in mind
that our tub is a tiny bit smaller than
the us one but overall we are still
better off than than in most of the
metrics
here is everything that's in the tub of
ben jerry's half baked in the uk cream
cream liquid sugar
sugar water condensed milk water
brown sugar
soybeans
eggs
seamless these are actually pretty much
identical lists so good job ben and
jerry there's also nothing in there
which you should be particularly
concerned about and this is kind of in
line with ben and jerry's overall
philosophy about sourcing ingredients
according to the ben jerry's website
they boast that their ice cream is
non-gmo fair trade and cage-free and
they do seem to live up to that all you
food wars heads watch in this episode
know that we always have to deal with
artificial flavors that are okay in the
us but not allowed in the european union
but the ones that ben and jerry use are
actually made with natural colors like
vegetable juice spirulina and turmeric
so while what's in the ice cream might
not be too interesting what's outside it
is actually worth pointing out in the
u.s the ben and jerry pines do come in a
cardboard tub that has polyurethane
plastic on both sides in the uk however
they've actually stopped coating the
outside of the tubs which makes them
more widely recyclable ben and jerry's
have said that it is their goal to
replicate this in the u.s at some point
this year which would save 79 000 pounds
of plastic a year that's it
got it how much chocolate do i have on
my face
ice cream that looks like um
my cat after he's had an upset stomach
you know a little present he'll leave on
the carpet